en bref dans l'affaire Farida belgou a
Joué les Tours le jugement a été rendu
aujourd'hui 5000 € d'amende pour la
principale intéressée 4000 pour son
accolie Dalila Hassan et 12000 € de
dommage et intérêt rappelez-vous c'était
il y a 2 ans en mars 2014 en pleines
élection municipal les deux femmes
membres du collectif radical journée du
retrait de l'école avaient accusé à tort
dans une vidéo sur Internet une
institutrice de l'école bloterie à jouer
les tours elle l'avait accusé d'avoir
organisé des attouchements entre élèves
de maternel en vue de l'application de
la théorie du genre des accusations qui
se sont très rapidement révélé sans
fondement en mars dernier Farida belgou
avait été mise en examen pour complicité
de diffamation envers l'enseignante on
écoute maître chautan l'avocat de Farida
belgou ce que je comprends moins dans
cette décision mais j'attends de lire le
le
jugement c'est que je n'ai pas entendu
dans les commentaire du magistrat et qui
a fait de longs commentaires que nous
étions en présence d'une diffamation
publique alors pour que nous soyons
condamnés il fallait que ce soit une
diffamation publique pour nous nous
avons invoqué la bonne foi mais ça a été
écarté mais on nous a pas répondu sur le
caractère de diffamation publique ou
privée
donc je crois que hélas cette affaire
aura une suite devant la cour d'appel
parce qu'il y a des éléments qui
mériteront d'être remis en cause mais
j'attends évidemment pour régulariser
cet appel d'une part la accord de ma
cliente et évidemment d'avoir lu le
jugement parce que c'est toujours très
intéressant de savoir comment le
tribunal a motivé une décision